Schmidt and henge is a family-owned
company in Berlin for 150 years it's
been making measuring instruments for
the pharmaceutical and food industries
the company has always exported its
highly specialized products these days
half of what it produces ends up outside
the European Union including in Japan
but its business in Japan has been
stagnating CEO Matta's Kishida says
Tokyo's regulatory requirements are a
burden for his company increasing costs
and complexity in Europe we already have
to undergo a large number of
certifications it's not really clear why
we have to go through the whole thing
again it drives up our costs by 30% on
the export market the customer ends up
paying we think the standards and
certifications we have in Europe should
be recognized abroad
he says his company would be much more
competitive in Japan if there were a
free trade agreement
Atsushi Mori yama also believes in the
importance of a free trade agreement
he's in charge of a unit of the Sumitomo
corporation that manufactures special
tools for the metalworking industry his
disel Dorf based company imports tools
and parts from japan and sells them all
over europe
the unit's revenue in the EU in 2013 was
a hundred million euros business is good
but more Yama says bureaucracy takes its
toll both in time and on morale every
three years customs inspectors come
around and conduct audits that last for
weeks making sure that Sumitomo has
declared everything correctly when we
import our factory in South Germany
this is 2.7 this is 5% but if you import
in the same package from our original in
fact our original R&D center then both
are 5% everything is also complicated
misleading and difficult so channel
sometimes more uyama is firmly convinced
there will be a free trade deal and he
hopes it comes soon but analysts say
there are many more rounds of
negotiations ahead before any agreement
can be signed